choix jamais de il a fait une interview
dans le huffington post et c'était hier
et depuis quelques semaines des rumeurs
indiqué que l'émission d'ardisson qui a
commencé cette année ne serait pas
renouvelé finalement thierry démons et
thierry ardisson je vous donnerai une
petite info de talent parce qu'il
m'envoyait un petit sms avant juste
avant l'émission
est ce que vous comprenez ces conditions
qu'il fasse ses deuxièmes un noir ça
semble un tout petit peu du chanteur
alors il a il a jamais dit alors vous le
dit thierry m'a envoyé d y en a un c'est
vrai cela dit j'ai jamais dit que je
faisais du chantage
ils ont voilà et c'est ce à quoi la
police ait eu ou rien il a juste dit
qu'il aimerait continuer les deux et
j'aurai une petite info vous donner
juste un procès bara et j'aimerais qu'il
soit alors ça arrive rarement mais je
suis entièrement d'accord avec lui ce
que les terriens du dimanche pour moi
c'est une des vraies créations de cette
émission est formidable parle aéropage
de gens divers moi je suis je trouve
honnêtement que la supprimer serait une
hérésie une hérésie titre alors c'est la
18 pb non alors n'y a pas que les b oui
alors je suis pas fan de lui mais
l'émission du samedi est une vraie
réussite c'est vrai on y découvre des
gens des ados ni des gens connus c'est
très bien écrit tous à celle du dimanche
totalement raté tout était prêt
tout est si plus tard vient pas du tout
est joliment quand on fait l'amour va
chercher l'image orne à l'image est
déplorable sauvage c'est l'audience et
l'audience ne marche pas non plus bas à
coûter mais c'est pas toi tu vas bien
alors j'ai qu'une quête il parle donc de
la sésamie avec quelqu'un que j'aime
beaucoup c'est marc-olivier fogiel qui
était donc forcément quand on parle de
tir à dix on est un peu énervé
oui non il m'avait invité dans son
émission de l'italien est ce que j'aime
pas ces vestiges effectivement comme
beaucoup quand on y va on est piégé il s
intéresse
c'était du dimanche est nul c'était des
gens qui parlent de sujets qu'ils ne
connaissent pas mais c'est passé si je
peux monter le toit ainsi vous allez me
crie dans l'oreille chef
si j'ai le choix via gabioud toi jean iv
qui tu crois alors il ya longtemps oui
mais il ay la vie de plus les vieilles
mais pourquoi me dit ça part vite tout
le monde tirait non non non mais je suis
pas fan non c'est vrai bon bah très bien
alors je suis assez d'accord il n'est
pas très correct à away assez positif
voilà mais on tue la pub est rien moi je
suis fâché page appartement mais pas sur
les missions du niveau culturel boeuf et
thomas fait partie la plus con car bien
des crises et drôle oui autre
information dans l'interview audio
fenton poste il
il raconte le retour de jeremstar aller
vite or la chaîne quand on l'a encore de
contact dit c'est en négociation c'est
absolument pas actée et on verra bien ce
qu'il en est a priori jeremstar va
revenir et je vous le dis d'après les
infos que j'ai ça se passe très très
bien et les négociations avec ses 8 est
tirée à 10 ans d'une bonne nouvelle
devrait revenir le samedi est libre et
le sait il a posé des conditions là
voilà ta pape mais tout le monde pose
des causes des saints pas aussi au mode
avait posé avec kyriba dit si je prends
pas le vendredi j'aurai que l'émission
battle est donné et que j'ai dit c'est
un menteur non mais très coûteux
[Applaudissements]
oui et donc tu es l'art des sons qui a
fait plein de révélations dans cette
interview sur le fun poste et le
journaliste notamment garés à souligner
a posé une question sur vous et on le
connaît très grande gueule très
provocateur plutôt friands de bons mots
pour le buzz
il lui a dit donc vous cyril hanouna
s'est imposée comme la tête d'affiche de
ses 8 est-ce que la place de numéro 2 ça
vous gêne pas donc une question quand
même assez violente et la répondu très
gentiment vous coûte que no more situera
il faut lire entre les lignes c'est 13
ans l'espagnol est la colonne vertébrale
de la chaîne il connaît que c'est une
très belle colonne vertébrale voilà
pense qu'il est phénoménal incroyable
ouais ah non il parle pas de moi là si
moi je fais par des tiges pendant deux
jours lui il arrive sur le made in the
tender
voilà donc je souhaite en prendre le
pognon il dit vous avez le pognon ils
n'ont pas les mêmes que lui que lui au
début vous avez vous venez du bas
excusez moi aurons et cyril excusez moi
mais je vous trouve pour une fois très
naïf bon alors c'est voir grande
humanité qui voit mais franchement là
des files à donner ni tableau
extrêmement politique coordonnée entre
les lignes il m'aide et alla tout le
monde voilà il fait pression sur la
chaîne en disant ces deux émissions avec
jeremstar ou rien moi je veux bien il se
place en homme fort quand on fait des
ultimatums comme ça en général je vais
vous dire on les perd voile avait mal
alors c'est lui laverai jamais c'est pas
très bien pris on voit là par amour on
n'a pas la même lecture
non le moigne à une chose qui m'a
interpellé c'est lorsqu'il a dit que et
c'est certainement vrai mais cos lui
thierry ardisson et pète sur n'importe
quelle chaîne entre les lignes il a donc
sa personnalité fait nommer soeur est-ce
que c'est l'abattoir il avait rien dit
si on est prêt à partir non c'est une
sensation
il a il amène ses téléspectateurs
excluant tout allait bien a précisé que
les séries de ses 800 craignos sa fin a
dit également ce passionné de sa fait
très bien fort du succès c'est allé un
peu fort